gracias por esta comunicación fernando
ochoa analista de inteligencia y riesgos
a la seguridad nacional ya se abrió una
investigación por intento de asesinato
así lo precisó la fiscalía local y dijo
mantenerse en estrecho contacto con la
autoridad nacional antiterrorista pero
al momento esto no se investiga como
ataque terrorista señor coche porque qué
elementos destaca de este ataque bueno
desde españa para mis compañeros de
colombia vamos a ver la de gs y la
dirección era de seguridad interior nos
hecho cargo de las investigaciones y lo
ha cedido a la policía judicial porque
al parecer según informaciones de la
propia prensa francesa de la pf ntv
parece ser que este sacerdote ortodoxo
había tenido problemas en su comunidad
por tanto no se descarta el hecho de que
sea una rencilla un programa personal y
no un ataque
terroristas contra un sacerdote
religioso ortodoxo entonces hay que
esperar un poco a la información pero en
poco al análisis en cualquier caso sigue
siendo un crimen de odio un crimen de
radicalización y veremos la motivación
si es que lo hubiera si es personal o es
religiosa señor cohecho que tanto
preocupa la situación actual de
tensiones del gobierno de manuel macro
ni los actos terroristas está bajo
ataque la seguridad nacional de francia
está bajo ataque la seguridad nacional
de toda europa y por qué decir casi de
todo el mundo
evidentemente france en estos momentos
según la ley de seguro nacional suya
está en el máximo grado de alerta
antiterrorista el siguiente paso ya
sería prácticamente la declaración de
enemigo abierto y de guerra no se puede
ya no pues no poder un nivel superior ya
de régimen no hay siete mil soldados no
policías siete mil soldados patrullando
las calles con órdenes directas
explícitas de intervenir y reducir
cualquier amenaza o riesgo a la
seguridad de cualquier persona y eso va
a llevarnos quizás a lo mejor en que las
próximas semanas tengamos a un conflicto
algún roce entre las fuerzas como es el
estado el ejército y la sociedad civil
esperemos que no pero a francia está en
alto riesgo altísimo riesgo de detención
o atentado como lo está españa como
estaba en otros países